[Applaudissements]
mais c'est ce soir le gros show sur des
vite
elle consacre une émission entière à
jean michel maire ce soir sur des vite
non mais non pour kubica est le gros
show de l'équipe c'est jean michel maire
mais enfin brice chaud chaud comme un
show ou avec un double match à auch à au
chaud et c'est cyril hanouna qui
présente ok c'est bien et qu'en plus il
tombe malade et ben moctar pourra le
remplacer ça fait pas de problème et oui
parce qu'ils feront le grand chose a
cassé la gueule pas trop chaud
si vous faites ça brille ça tu fais là
je viens de commander un hummer pop au
nom de cyril hanouna devant chez cyril
hanouna attendait bougeait pas oui taxis
g7 je dis ça je dis rien cyril hanouna
vous savez le paquet mais il vient de
commander un beurre pop devant son
domicile
voilà vous voyez vous voyez où je veux
en venir voilà merci cordialement
oui mais bon là on est débarrassé
fleurus mais vous avez commandé
quelconque le à bas le vôtre bertrand le
vôtre plus que trois émissions avant la
quille ont frappé fort cette semaine
faire de l'inédit quelque chose qu'on
n'a jamais fait non love crade et ben on
pourrait faire un épisode drôle trop
ambitieux
[Musique]
oui à ces quatre ans ce sujet d'année
proche al harra maloba haye a coupé le
passé sous un tunnel alors bertrand
comment ça ça valait vous donc j'ai le
relevé des apparitions de cyril hanouna
ce week-end à lattes et ça dit quoi
abbas a dit plutôt pas mal il est encore
partout les enfants de la télé sur tf1
bam ensuite sur france 2 le plus grand
cabaret du monde et comme il était bien
sur france 2 eh ben il est resté jusqu'à
faire on n'est pas couché juste après et
donc vous vous étiez où bertrand
soutiennent gt
si vous avez où on a pu me voir en
terrasse j'ai bu des coups avec des avec
les potes mais non pertes rang mais il
faut être partout il faut être comme
hanouna il est partout 7 jours sur 7
france 2 tf1 canal partout j'ai même
fait dans le film de mariage de la
cousine de ce week-end ah oui mais pour
vous dire il est partout fabrice il ne
reste que trois émissions j'ai vraiment
plus d'espoir je n'arriverai jamais à
prendre la place du paquis chic
on est fort
[Musique]
c'est non
je suis venu te dire que je m'en veux
[Musique]
et de mon épouse
ou rien changé
don
si tu veux t'en vas
[Musique]
jamie
pas d'autres mots
[Musique]
que tout le monde
il dit
c'est fou ce truc de toujours tout
rendre dégueulasse je mens c'est gênant
par sa part sympa puis c'est dégueu quoi
bonnes vacances
ben non ça après journée à deux jours la
fin on n'a toujours pas atteint notre
but de m'embaucher pour quoi vous servez
à quoi
bertrand mais vous êtes nuls
vous prenez pas ça vous savez vous savez
même pas à la cheville de cyril ces
minutes tout ce que vous faites vous
êtes nuls c'est tout mais vous c'est pas
drôle
j'arrive là non je suis dans persona non
non non fabrice quelle chaleur je
souffrais dire qu'apple activement cette
foutue prod mais passer quelque chose
mais moins ventilo non je peux voir mais
animal si vous voulez quels rapports qui
brassent beaucoup d'air
j'aime votre style canicule est le
gouvernement recommande de prendre le
plus grand soin des personnes âgées
ouais gérard tout va bien ok non c'est
tout c'est tout c'est bon je vous
rappelle isabelle morini bosc